[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france 24 il exactement six mois le
15 août les talibans ont surpris le
monde en prenant le pouvoir à kaboul le
président ashraf ghani s'est enfui mais
son prédécesseur hamid karzaï a décidé
de rester jones il est avec nous depuis
kaboul merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
monsieur karzaï
merci monsieur perryman joel à ce titre
votre invitation
je veux commencer avec la situation
humanitaire dans votre pays deux
chiffres donnés par les nations unies
sont frappantes twenty twenty two ici
l'ami 2022 97% des afghans vont plonger
dans la pauvreté up to one et jusqu'à un
million d'enfants que moins de cinq ans
pourraient mourir d'ici la fin de
l'année en
réaction à ces chiffres terribles
je ne peux pas certifier ces chiffres
je ne peux pas confirmer ce chiffre
alors oui le fait est que l'économie du
pays souffrent date de plus les
privations ont augmenté à date
les opportunités d'emploi cône sud ont
baissé considérablement du dews
considérablement battus ces dames et one
mais dire qu'un million d'enfants vont
mourir que 97% de la population tombera
dans la pauvreté
cela je ne peux pas le confirmer
j'espère que ce n'est pas vrai
j'espère de tout mon coeur comme tout
afghan
aucun enfant afghans ne mourra et il est
de notre responsabilité
si cela devait survenir de l'empêcher
oui évidemment on voit à travers ces
chiffres terribles que l'aide
humanitaire est absolument clé l'aide
financière plus largement qui
la prise de pouvoir des talibans le
gouvernement américain a gelé 7
milliards de dollars de fonds
gouvernementaux afghans aux états unis
il ya quelques jours le président biden
a décidé que la moitié de cette somme
qui ré à l'aide humanitaire à
l'afghanistan et l'autre moitié serait
dédiée aux familles et des attaques du
11 septembre brice d'état la bonne
qualité que le gouvernement de
transition afghan a prévenu que si cela
était mise en place
il y aurait des conséquences terribles
pour les relations avec les états unis
view quelle est votre vision sur cette
décision de l'administration baden
d'une part je ne confirme pas ces
chiffres
de ces chiffres des nations unies mais
d'autre part oui l'afghanistan a besoin
d'assistance humanitaire l'afghanistan a
besoin d'assistance financière
nous accueillons avec satisfaction toute
assistance de la part de nos amis
du monde entier et notamment
l'assistance financière bien sûr
sur la question des réserves des avoirs
de l'afghanistan tisse
ses avoirs appartenant au peuple afghan
c'est à voir n'appartiennent à aucun
gouvernement
la majeure partie de ses avoirs a été
collecté sous ma présidence mais ce ne
sont pas les avoir de l'air karzaï ou du
gouvernement karzaï
pas plus qu'aujourd'hui
c'est à voir m'appartiennent aux
talibans qui sont au pouvoir ce sont les
avoirs du peuple afghan
est tout autant une victime que les
victimes de la tragédie du 11 septembre
et même davantage
fondé afghans ont souffert du terrorisme
pendant bien plus longtemps
il y a eu bien plus de pertes humaines
que lors des attentats
alors bien sûr nous compatissons avec
les victimes qu'un duo ce temps nous
sommes du côté des victimes ou et donc
vous fait que le président biden
saisissent la moitié des réserves
nationales et qui les halles ou à ses
victimes
il s'agit là d'un dernier du statut de
victime du peuple afghan c'est
moralement répréhensible donc j'y suis
fortement opposés je suis opposé à cette
décision nous voulons que l'intégralité
de ses avoirs soient réservés à
l'afghanistan pour les générations
futures pour notre politique monétaire
pour la stabilité de notre devise
nationale
donc j'éprouve un profond désaccord
je préfère dire au peuple américain que
les afghans ont souffert tout autant que
les américains lors de cette journée
tragique du 11 septembre que nous
compatissons et que nous devons être
ensemble pour trouver des solutions et
pour trouver des solutions aux douleurs
des deux côtés aux souffrances des deux
côtés
les afghans
sont des victimes légitime et mérite de
la compassion donc ces avoirs doivent
être laissées intactes carouge
appartiennent au peuple afghan
et je demande au président by donne de
revenir sur sa décision
et de rendre ces avoirs au peuple afghan
de ce dessin a bien compris c'est
évidemment lié au fait qu' aucun pays
étranger n'a reconnu les talibans pour
le moment est-ce que vous demander à la
communauté internationale de reconnaître
les talibans on sait qu'il ya eu des
négociations à oslo en ce moment m à
doha est-ce que vous pensez que cette
reconnaissance est nécessaire ont
recouvré d'accord avec la communauté
internationale en raison de l'expérience
passée des talibans et de leurs
attitudes cette reconnaissance ne doit
pas donné immédiatement
les talibans aujourd'hui sur le
gouvernement de facto de l'afghanistan
sur la question de la reconnaissance du
gouvernement taliban par la communauté
internationale et ma proposition depuis
le tout début est la suivante nous le
peuple afghan nous devons avant tout
balayer devant notre porte et to be all
ofas en tout le monde l'ensemble du
peuple afghan ceux qui sont d'accord
avec ce qui se passe aujourd'hui en
afghanistan et ceux qui ont des
divergences de désaccord vis-à-vis du
gouvernement actuel de l'afghanistan
tout le monde doit se réunir à travers
les traditions et les institutions
afghanes nous devons travailler ensemble
pour trouver une solution pour un avenir
meilleur
et le gouvernement taliban actuelle a la
responsabilité de prendre en compte tous
les habitants venant de toutes les
sphères sociales il doit réunir tout le
monde pour discuter ensemble de l'avenir
du pays et il faut que les décisions
prises soient prises à travers la
volonté des peuples cette volonté doit
s'exprimer et la reconnaissance suivre
ont-ils répondu
vous l'ancien chef exécutif abdullah
abdullah leur avait demandé de convoquer
loya jirga grande assemblée
traditionnelle mais ils ne l'ont pas
fait est ce qu'ils vous ont dit qu'ils
ne l'en voulait pas c'est hors de
question pour eux
n'ont pas dit ça ils ont
plutôt bien reçu notre lettre
ils l'ont pris en compte
et l'on étudié et donc espérons que si
l'occasion se présente tous les afghans
pourront se réunir et faire des plans
pour l'avenir tous les afghans venant de
toutes les sphères de la somme de
discorde notamment avec les pays
occidentaux et l'éducation des filles
des écoles sont censés ouvrir le mois
prochain au mois de mars les talibans
ont indiqué qu'ils permettraient
peut-être aussi de retourner à l'école
est ce que pour vous c'est une
obligation
est-ce que vous pensez que les talibans
vont le permettre ou y mettre certaines
limites
universities les universités dans les
régions les plus chaudes du pays ont
rouvert
les fils sont retournés en classe de
secours
que les écoles rouvriront dans
l'ensemble du pays eh bien les filles
devront sans aucun doute retourner à
leurs études iv mais même si la
communauté internationale même si
l'occident n'appelait pas le
gouvernement actuel à permettre aux
filles de retourner à l'école c'est la
volonté du peuple afghan avant tout
c'est un besoin du peuple afghan à
venteuse et donc le retour des filles à
l'école et à l'université et le retour
des femmes au travail nos fromages ne
peut pas faire l'objet de compromis
c'est un impératif absolu pour le
bien-être de notre est ce que les
talibans vont le permettre mais d'après
vos interactions avec eux
ah
je pense que c'est ce qui se passera il
n'y a pas d'autre solution à watsco bac
je veux retourner
au mois d'août juste avant la chute de
kaboul vous et abdullah abdullah
l'ancien chef exécutif était en
négociations avec les talibans
vous pensiez
éviter ce qui s'est passé mais le
président ghani a soudainement quitté le
pays est ce que vous pensez vraiment
qu'il y aurait pu avoir un deal avec les
talibans ou est ce que ce n'est pas une
réécriture de l'histoire
ah non je suis absolument convaincu que
si la situation avait été gérée
différemment
si on avait été un peu plus rapide dans
le processus de paix que ce soient les
pays qui participaient
le gouvernement de l'époque
que l'issue aurait été différente on
aurait pu avoir un mécanisme national et
le pays aurait pu éviter en grande
partie le désastre et l'humiliation qui
se sont abattues sur nous beaucoup de
choses se sont passées ce jour là le 15
août le président du conseil de paix
monsieur abdallah et moi même nous
avions préparé une liste de dignitaires
qui pouvait se rendre à doha le jour
même ou le lendemain pour discuter avec
les dirigeants talibans et négocier un
accord qui aurait convenu à l'ensemble
du pays et qui aurait pu conserver
l'intégrité du pays et le caractère
intacte de ses institutions
malheureusement cela ne s'est pas passé
comme ça dernière question est-ce que
vous en voulez au président gagny pour
cela et aussi plus largement pour la
façon dont il a quitté l'afghanistan
ait pu me rejette la faute sur personne
j'aurais simplement aimé que les choses
se passent différemment
l'organiste ans serait dans une bien
meilleure situation aujourd'hui
awana thank you hamid karzaï merci
beaucoup pour votre temps et merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions et merci
à vous d'avoir regardé cet entretien sur
france 24
[Musique]
le 25 décembre 1991 marque la
dissolution de l'urss éclatant en quinze
états indépendants nos reporters se sont
rendus en ukraine en estonie et en
géorgie trois anciennes républiques
soviétiques
tiraillé entre influence russe et
européenne
[Musique]
trente ans après l'effondrement du bloc
soviétique
une nouvelle bataille géopolitique se
jouent à coups de propagande de chars et
de hackers c'est vrai tu as khroub et
acs
billet retour en urss à retrouver sur
france 24 et france 24 points comme
[Musique]
pour mieux comprendre le français ici on
commençait par l'écouté vous écouter rfi
il est 20 heures en temps universel en
sciences la tête dans les étoiles
l'astronaute thomas pesquet devra garder
les pieds sur terre pour mener ses
expériences
l'astronaute thomas pesquet devra garder
les pieds sur terre pour mener ses
expériences sur le blob
apprenait le français avec l'actualité
sur rfi savoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]